okay this is a question that i have
never openly
talked about and something that a lot of
people have brought to my attention
and criticized me for hey everyone i'm
abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today i will be talking to one of your
favorite content creators
linda sun as part of my new series
well-fed and fed up here we're going to
be talking about
diet culture body image mental health
and so much more
every episode i'm going to be sitting
down with a fellow influencer or
content creator to ask some really tough
questions
and have some real uncensored unscripted
discussions
without the shame and judgment because
we're all a little fed up with wellness
culture
right now before we dive in a quick
reminder to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning uh to those
with past or previous experiences with
disordered eating
i also want to remind you guys to
subscribe to the channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode
hey linda thank you so much for joining
me today
i am really excited to be chatting with
you me too
thank you for having me abby it's an
honor so first and foremost for those
who might not know you well
who is linda sutton i am a 20 year old
university student who has always had a
passion for food and eating and baking
and exercising i'd say i'm just a pretty
normal average girl who's still on her
journey of building and molding her
relationship with food and exercise and
her body and self-confidence just like
any other 20 year old probably is
the only difference is i film it and i
document it for a couple people to watch
my videos are kind of all about like
enjoying food enjoying life and sharing
my own experiences and things i've
learned along my journey but honestly
what i want others to think of when they
think of linda sun
is just pancakes popcorners lots of
peanut butter
and like a sweaty hot mess basically i
love that i love just being you know
known for
popcorn and things like that that's
amazing um now of course you want to
dive into some more
sensitive topics and i know that the
past few
weeks and months have been intense to
say
the least so how have you been feeling
when the cameras are off
my platform in this community that we've
built and that continues to grow every
day
has been a space where i can be myself
or i can be vulnerable and i can be
honest with who i am and what i think
but yeah also over the past few months i
have been sucked into uh
the darker side of youtube i guess you
could say the side where i don't think
any youtuber wants
to be sucked into and everything
positive and kind and encouraging kind
of just turned
into hatefulness and body shaming i no
longer felt
like this was my safe space anymore you
know i didn't really know how to handle
the hate
i was getting for just being me so yeah
it's been a couple long months of me
just doing a lot of self-reflecting and
trying to understand how i feel
because when the cameras are off i've
honestly just been a little bit confused
and a little bit lost and i honestly
think that's totally fine you don't
always have to know the answer to
everything or be okay with everything
or even understand what you're feeling
in the moment okay so let's talk about
the video that made a little bit of
uproar on youtube about having your
calories for a week
now i know that you really aim to eat
intuitively and are really not about
denial or restriction so i'm curious
what was the thinking behind
that challenge yeah if i'm gonna be
honest i have tried to block that
time and that video out of my memory
completely but
going into making that video i already
knew it was gonna be a controversial one
but i didn't
anticipate how extreme the controversy
would be and
definitely did not expect a certain
length that certain people would take
that video too
people who've actually watched my videos
know that i've been through quite a
complicated relationship with food
and i've come a long way and that does
not mean my relationship with food is
perfect in any way it's far from it and
i'm
still learning and growing and figuring
it out along the way and i would never
ever promote or encourage restriction
drastically cutting calories forbidden
foods that's just not what i'm about
and people that actually watch my videos
would know that i know that and that was
not the message i was trying to get
across
i think the point of video there was a
personal side and there was also a
trying to prove a larger point side i
actually was curious and wanted to see
what would happen to my hunger and my
mood and my cravings if i were to cut my
calories drastically because i knew
nothing good was going to come out of
this experiment i wanted to show that to
my audience i thought i made it pretty
clear that i wasn't trying to promote
restriction
because i'm always saying like you do
you do what makes you feel like the best
version of you the healthiest version of
you that's counting every calorie if
that's intuitive eating
following any diet eating right before
bed whatever it is
i'm always advocating for people to do
what's best for their bodies and their
lives
i think people didn't really see that or
maybe i could have been clearer or said
it better
or they thought i was blaming calorie
counting for my problems i don't really
know
but definitely yeah was not my intention
to offend anyone
yeah i i could say the same thing about
so many of my videos where i'm like
i you know i provide a disclaimer at one
point
and and i didn't later on in the video
and people will call me out for that
not really maybe watching the whole
thing or not seeing the context
or the greater picture it is so hard to
try to be
you know a content creator and make
everybody happy you just can't so i'm
glad to hear that you're trying to
kind of come to terms with that because
i think that's so important for
mental health um now you did turn off
the comment section
on that video was that done in part
because of the public reaction from your
audience
or do you feel that kind of reactions
from other creators
sent a wave of unnecessary targeted
attacks
on you i used to love
the comment section of my videos i still
do it it brings me so much joy and
empowers me
to see everyone supporting each other
and encouraging each other and honestly
like hyping each other up like you guys
like are incredible and i think that
video changed everything for me there
were a lot of great comments
really kind comments but because i think
the message of the video was
misconstrued
and i also think we're so easily
influenced by other people and their
opinions and their comments
and so when someone takes time out of
their day to construct a long
hate comment or video about me i'm not
surprised
that the hate started to overpower the
kind comments
so did i feel attacked
kind of you know like i feel like who
wouldn't do i think that people decided
to hate on
me and my channel my content before
trying to understand me or my message
or my audience yes but do i think people
are entitled to their own opinions
of course and unfortunately what i've
realized is hate is always going to
exist it doesn't matter how pure your
intentions
are but i can't know or control what
other people are going to think or
comment i just had to kind of step back
and
realize not everyone's going to like me
or agree with what i stand for i have to
be okay with that
yeah i know it's such a hard realization
to come to but i also think
important for our mental health as
creators
um but what was your first reaction when
you started to see
some of that criticism and all the
response videos and things like that
like you know as a fellow content
creator who have had
many people create response videos to me
because i also create response videos
i know that that can feel like a lot so
i'm curious how you dealt with that
okay the way i like to see my channel my
platform and the entire purpose of just
what i do
is just to spread positivity and love
and for a long long time it was such a
positive space for me and for others
a place like i mentioned before was just
safe and yeah
hate and criticism you know constructive
or not is it's just a part of being a
content creator but because i've never
gotten so much criticism and so much
hate for what i do and who i
am and because i'm still quite new to
the whole youtube
environment like i only started a little
over a year ago
i was quite shocked i felt overshadowed
and i felt silenced i felt like i didn't
have
a place or the right to fight for myself
to stand up for myself
i kind of felt really hopeless for
a really long time but after you know
being able to reflect
on the comments and the hate i feel like
it was a really really necessary
learning experience for me and i'm not
gonna sit here and lie and say that it
didn't hurt me because reading
thousands upon thousands of hateful
comments about me is not something i
particularly like to spend my free time
doing
but getting through that time in my life
and having to experience all the hateful
comments on youtube and the
aggressive dms on instagram and the
hateful videos made about me
it just made me stronger and it was hard
at first but everything seems difficult
before you go through it you know and
looking back at the video
do you regret like the process or
specific things that you said
or did or making the video in general
like are there things that you would
have changed
in retrospect yeah i've thought about
this
quite a lot like my life maybe just
would have been so much easier if i just
didn't make
such a controversial video but i don't
think i regret it i mean i've been
thinking about making this video for
quite a long time and i probably would
have ended up making it sooner or later
and to be honest
i was proud of that video i'm still
proud of that video and i think i got
the message i wanted to get across to
the people who i think
needed to see that video what i don't
think people realize sometimes is that
i am just a person i'm just human like
i'm gonna be making mistakes and i'm
gonna say the wrong things
and for me like that video was just a
way for me to say that you are deserving
of fullness and eating and fueling your
body it really wasn't meant to do any
harm to anyone and if people are going
to take that video and define me through
it
go ahead that's okay i really do
apologize though to the people that may
have been offended by that video but no
i i don't regret it
yeah i mean the reality is the public
needs to realize that
content creators are not you know or not
above
making mistakes even i'm a professional
i have a degree
i am you know like this is my job and
yet i
still make mistakes people call me out
like oh my gosh she must know nothing
because she
made a small heir you know what we're
human like there is so much going
on i'm juggling a lot of things we are
all
subject to mistakes and i think as long
as you
um are you know transparent about that
you are willing to learn from your
mistakes i think that says a lot
about um you know your personality and
who you are professionally
and also just like how much you care for
your audience in general so
i mean nobody is above like making
mistakes and we all don't know
everything so i think the public just
needs to
needs to figure that one out
okay so i want to talk about uh your
most recent video at the time of filming
this
so you mentioned gaining 20 pounds
and learning to love your body after
having you know a history of
having a more complicated relationship
with food so
obviously a lot of my followers are in
the same camp right now especially with
covet
is there a mantra that you use to help
reassure you
and your trust in your body and just
your general intuitive
eating approach yeah change is never
easy especially when it comes to you
know your own body but i came across
this like real or something the other
day that summarizes
exactly what i tell myself in a much
better way and whenever i'm feeling out
of tune with my body i always tell
myself something like this
it went something like the entire
purpose of your body is not to
display it to the world it's it's not
just for others to see
your body carries you through life and
keeps you alive and lets you experience
the world it needs nourishment it needs
love and it needs compassion
point of your body is not to look
perfect it's not to be a certain weight
it's not to be a certain size
so you just gotta cut your body some
slack and
say thank you especially like after
weight gain like
i find myself constantly telling myself
you are worthy of food in every freaking
size okay
as cliche as it is i always tell myself
life's just too short it's too short to
ruin you know beautiful summer days and
nights out with friends
and celebrations because you're too
stressed out about a couple of extra
pounds
it's too short to be so upset when you
could just be enjoying life and it's
just too short for me to be constantly
at war with my own body oh yeah that's
kind of what i tell myself
when i'm having one of those bad days
yeah i really i really appreciate that
and you know
we all go through seasons of life where
we feel more or less comfortable in our
own skin
and you know myself being a second time
mom you know i'm still in the kind of
postpartum
phase of life and um you know i
i think i'm in the best place of my even
though like i'm like probably like the
heaviest i've ever been
um i'm on the best place ever in terms
of my just my like
my mentality around my body because i've
just been able to witness like
holy [ __ ] look at what it does and then
also like you said like life is too
short i
you know it's summertime i remind myself
one of my friends posted on instagram
you only get 18 summers with your kids
like put that
into perspective and i it makes you
think like
i only have 18 like these are counting
down i can't waste
a single day thinking like worrying
about not
you know about having the ice cream or
not having the ice cream like i'm just
gonna have the
ice cream because i want my kids to see
me enjoying
that experience with them so yeah i
think that
thinking of things in in terms like that
really does put it into perspective
um because honestly you know you want to
feel good you want to you know fuel your
body with great nutrition and that's
important and i think you
you really demonstrate that beautifully
in your in your videos how you can
balance a lot of nutritious and
nutrient-dense foods
with pleasure and enjoyment and
experience around food
and i think that's a really important
piece of
finding health and happiness so i think
you did a great job at
showcasing that now let's talk
about some of your content in general
because clearly i'm a big fan
and i binge watch a lot of your content
and i think it's beautifully shot
and amazingly edited and also just so
inspirational and fun
so i'm curious about your strategy just
as a fellow content creator
with click bait because i noticed you
put a lot of pictures
of like your body and the thumbnails and
there's a lot of talk
about weight gain or weight loss in the
titles but your actual content seems to
communicate
a more body neutral kind of food freedom
approach
so i'm curious what your thinking is on
this and and like how do you
personally reconcile these competing
strategies
and messages with your content okay this
is a question that i have
never openly talked about and something
that a lot of people have brought to my
attention
and criticized me for call me
disingenuous and fake and insincere and
i get it and i'm honestly not going to
argue and say it's not clickbait because
it is but if you see my content you're
right the message the thumbnail portrays
than the actual message the video sends
are literally completely contrasting
ideas i think the reason i do
what i do is because that helps me reach
the audience that i think i need to
reach
i think it's because when i was younger
i was obsessed with watching videos
titled the same way that i titled my
videos
how to lose weight fast how to lose fat
from here and there
i watched every single what i eat in a
week to compare and contrast see what i
should or should not eat to look like
them and that's just such a toxic
community to grow up in and such a
terrible message being sent to people
like i don't think any youtuber told me
that i was okay just
as me and i think that really took a
toll on the way i perceived my body
and impacted my self-confidence and
relationship with food till this very
day
so i want to be that person i wish i had
when i was younger
i want to be there for the people who
are like me from my past
searching through all these videos
comparing and contrasting and tell them
that
you are strong and you are enough and
you are beautiful
just as you are and there is so much
more to life than the pressure you put
on yourself to look a certain way
there's way more to life than
restriction that food
is a part of life and not all of life
and that a healthy relationship with
food and exercise and themselves
is so possible and while i do not have
the most perfect relationship with any
of those things
i have come a long way and i do want to
share what i've learned with as many
people as possible and i think the best
way to do that
is how i'm doing it right now if you
hate that i'm sorry but you don't have
to watch
that's just me yeah i mean i get some of
the same feedback sometimes it's like
i remember uh like creating videos and
things like that
being like how to detox your body and
like
when you actually watch it you're like
oh you just need
a lot some lungs you need to like take
and like
go go to the bathroom but it's like
you're trying to to reach the people who
need this message most because those are
people who are searching for
some of these like wellness
pseudoscience like diet
culture messages um and you're coming in
there
with the truth with the truth bombs so
yeah it's obviously a strategy and this
is youtube so you have to expect that
everything is a little sensationalized
um that's that's what gets
people to to watch your content and i
think as long as what you are
communicating
in that content is legit and
it is in my opinion in your case and in
my case
um then i think that that that's a
totally
fair um uh fair fair way to to
structure your content so it's a great
strategy in my opinion but i get
i get the criticism i get it too um but
that's just also
my opinion as a fellow creator now you
are still
somewhat new to the crazy youtube troll
world uh but clearly you've had to catch
up pretty quick because your influence
is huge um but a lot of people don't
realize how much of a toll this all can
take on
us content creators i actually hear from
a lot of content creators constantly how
emotionally
taxing it all is and that you know
burnout is
really real so i'm curious
how do you deal with the criticism or
the trolling in general
how do you how do you get past that and
i'm still new to this whole world and
still confused about how i feel about
everything
because i am the luckiest person in the
world i am so
so grateful that i have this opportunity
to connect to so many people
and none of it literally none of it
feels real
ever i can't even process it right now
like talking to you like i can't process
it
it all feels very very very just surreal
with that being said knowing that i'm so
so so forever grateful for everything
that's come into my life
sometimes i feel like i'm just never
going to be enough or be able to say the
right thing i can never do
the right thing and you're right burnout
is so freaking real
and i'm not even just burnt out i think
i'm burnt and scared
i'm scared to say the wrong thing
because there's no right thing to say
sometimes because everyone has such a
different opinion
and the last thing i want to do is
offend anyone and the only way i'm not
going to offend anyone is if i keep my
mouth shut
i think that's what hurts the most i'm
scared because
everything i do is wrong however i love
youtube
and just because i'm scared doesn't mean
i'm going to quit so what i've been
doing to you know
deal with it is really just reminding
myself like what real life actually is
surrounding myself with people that
support me and ground me in real life i
surround myself with people
that see me for more than just the
videos i make and the mistakes i make
and the brands i work
with i don't look at numbers anymore i
don't care for views i'm just trying to
find
joy in creating and posting the things
that i'm proud of and trying not to put
too much pressure on myself
to be perfect because someone is always
going to have something bad to say
and i just can't control that so i just
focus on what i can control and try to
be kind to myself
and do what i feel is right because at
the end of the day you know that's
kind of all i can really do so yeah um
i i could have said everything that you
just said and more and it's like
there was always going to be somebody
who's offended
by your content i mean as an example i
remember
i got feedback once because i used the
you know the pronoun like she or her or
woman
in regards to talking about you know
menstruation
and so in future videos i tried to be
more inclusive
and use like more kind of inclusive
language saying like people who
menstruate
and then i got criticism by being like
too politically correct or
or saying something that's stupid or
doesn't make sense to them
so you really can't you can't
please everyone i think that's the
bottom line and you just have to like
accept that like someone's gonna be mad
about something
all the time and if you can't accept
that like
you really are not going to be able to
to to move forward
in this in this space because it's just
it's non-stop hate yeah
so i i totally feel you on that one
but i'm curious has any of this
criticism
changed like your content planning or
your approach to videos
um are you like now finding yourself
having to think more about the
unintended interpretations with your
audience or
are you mainly just like thinking about
entertainment value
and like what you want to put out there
i am scared to post controversial
content
i'm genuinely afraid and anxious before
i post videos
when i'm editing when i'm thinking about
what to say and the message i'm trying
to send
the criticism was good it taught me a
lot it has definitely taken a toll on me
and the content i make and it's kind of
made me feel unwelcome in the space that
i created
with the intention of trying to make
everyone feel as welcome as possible and
it's kind of sad
that this is the space i now feel
unwelcome in yeah i just realized i have
to be more careful with what i say
with the words i choose to use with my
disclaimers and trigger warnings and i
have to be careful with the topics i
choose to speak on
basically i just feel like i'm walking
on eggshells all the time and it was
never like that before the hate and the
criticism got more intense but as i said
like
i am stronger and i'm trying to learn
from it and hate is always gonna be
around us and i realize it's on me to
let that hate affect me and
bring me down or for me to like rise
above it and carry on
over time i hope i can go back to how i
used to be and like be a little bit more
carefree and like not be afraid to speak
my mind
yeah i went through phases myself where
after like a first
heavy wave of criticism not unlike what
you experienced
i really felt the need to like
scrutinize every word
every sentence like lots of disclaimers
like super politically correct
and then i was like this is so
exhausting it's no longer
enjoyable for me to be a content creator
because i felt like
every sentence that i had to say had to
be
prefaced with like 10 previous sentences
to just like
create context and that's challenging so
i have
been able to try to i have been trying
to find a balance
of what disclaimers are necessary and
what are people just going to have to be
responsible for themselves you know i
can't
i can't hold everyone's hand through
every single trigger because
even things that i don't think about
there's gonna be somebody who is
offended by
something i say or do so it has been a
real learning opportunity i think in
general i'm a pretty sensitive person
just
by nature so this does come naturally to
me to think more empathetically and more
sensitively to others
but it definitely can kind of take it to
an extreme where it becomes
really unenjoyable for me and also feels
like i'm watering down
a message so yeah i totally feel you on
that
but um as a dietitian you know like
my content i often think about my
content as kind of like infotainment
so evidence informed and educational but
still wrapped up
in like an entertaining way so how do
you see the purpose of
your content and i'm also curious how
if at all do you believe that it can be
utilized to like
improve people's relationship with food
i never
craft my videos or created my channel
with the intention of educating people
or think that i had the right or the
qualifications to tell people how to eat
or exercise or live their lives
as i've been saying i'm a student i'm
20. i don't have a degree
i'm in school i'm not a professional and
i literally sound like my disclaimer
blurb right now but
anyways for every video i make i make it
thinking i'm more of a lifestyle
youtuber but my videos are focused on
topics
about food and body image and
self-confidence and fitness
i've never seen myself being a health or
fitness youtuber or wellness youtuber
i'm just
me i vlog my life i edit and i eat a lot
of food
and i never thought that i could help
people
but after sharing my thoughts around
food and exercise after sharing my story
and how i listened to my body and seeing
me is just like a typical
average girl i think it gives people
hope or at least i hope it does because
if you were to tell me that i'd be here
with my relationship with food and my
body
before i would never believed you
honestly with my channel i just want to
give people a little bit of hope
happiness positive vibes leave my
channel feeling something or a little
bit better about themselves
it has never been my intention to teach
or educate or
change lives or act like i know more
than anyone because i'm honestly just
sharing
as like a friend my own experiences and
thoughts and my mistakes and lessons
i've learned along the way and that's
all i just
want to be a friend i love that we all
need friends on this journey
so uh what are you totally
fed up with in the wellness community
because i got a lot of things i'm fed up
about but i'm curious what's what's
what's
what's pissing you off i don't want to
get into it because there's just so much
controversy surrounding the wellness
community
even though it's such a welcoming
community and accepting community like
for some reason we're not doing a very
good job of accepting everyone
i think the biggest thing for me is like
i
feel like i'm not allowed to want to
change like i can want
to change and still love myself and i
can still be an advocate for body love
and acceptance
like health is so different for everyone
i'm tired of people thinking that
there's only like one
right way also it's my body it's my
choice to do whatever i want with
it and eat whatever i want move it the
way i want and i'm sick of people
telling me that the right way for me
is wrong what does that even mean
someone always has something bad to say
there are so many opinions health has
just become you know so complicated and
you know there's good and bad to that
but sometimes you know i just
want to live my life yeah there's
definitely like a lot of gatekeeping
around
certain terms and and and i think that a
lot of people feel
like they can't respect their body or
love their body while also
desiring to change their body and you
know i've grappled with this for a
really long time i've got a whole video
about where i
am in this whole haze versus weight loss
continuum
and i think for me it's come down to
acknowledging that
i believe in body autonomy i believe
that everybody has a right to
want to change their body and it makes
sense in such you know
a body focused fat phobic world that
we're in diet culture obsessed world
we're living in even if you love your
body and respect your body
i mean it makes sense that some days you
just want to change it so
i'm i'm kind of in the camp of body
neutrality
um and really focusing more on
respecting your body rather than
kind of obsessively loving it every
single day
i'm not sure that that's like a
realistic place for most people to
to be in and i don't think that it means
that you know you can't be a supporter
of intuitive eating or you can't be a
supporter
of body positivity or that community
if you don't um love your body 24 7.
so yeah i feel you on that too now
final question what do you want my
community to know
about your message like who does it
serve best
who is it safe for and who is it maybe
not safe for
okay uh first of all i just want to say
abby i'm just so glad
that you're on this platform you are a
channel that i think we need
in this time in this day and age you
have helped millions of people
and taught me so much so yeah i just
wanted to thank you for everything that
you do
for me i'm not qualified i'm not a
dietitian and i'm not a professional
so if you're looking for a channel with
you know science-backed professional
educational content i'm sorry i don't
think i'm your girl
i think i'm just trying to send good
vibes encourage self-love and body
acceptance
and i just want to share the changes in
my life and the changes in my mindset
that have made
accepting my body possible and i want to
share that with people in the hopes that
it can maybe
help them find peace with their bodies
and their relationship with food the way
it did with mine i kind of want
to seem like i'm with you along this
journey like we're doing it together
just me and you with a lot of amazing
food
a few inspirational quotes a little too
much peanut butter
and just acceptance all around so yeah
that's who i am that's my channel and i
know it's not for everyone
but i want you to know you're always
welcome to pay a visit whenever
amazing and yeah everybody should be
paying a visit
so thank you so much linda this was so
amazing
um of course i'm gonna be linking to
linda's channel below
um but again so happy that you were able
to come on to chat
thanks for having me abby bye guys and
thank all of you guys for watching
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next
in my fed up series subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you